let's think a little bit how energy
flows
and how
matter is recycled in an ecosystem and
so the whole time that we go through
this video think about these two ideas
and then even after watching this video
look at ecosystems around yourself even
ones that you are part of and think
about how energy flows and how matter is
recycled so let's first think about
energy so the energy for most ecosystems
originally comes from the sun there are
other sources of energy you can think
about even moonlight but that
essentially comes from the sun but
there's also geothermal energy but the
sun is a source of most energy for most
ecosystems we can think of
and how does the ecosystem make use of
that energy how does that get into how
does that get stored within the
ecosystem especially as biomass well it
starts with primary producers which are
usually going to be plants they can also
be
bacteria that are able to
photosynthesize
or that are able to take that energy and
create biomolecules that store energy
from it and so these are primary
primary producers these plants in this
diagram
sometimes you'll see them referred to as
autotrophs
they are getting their own food from
from the sun from this energy
and once again how is that energy stored
well it's stored in these biological
molecules if you were to zoom in into
the molecules in this plant and this is
a huge oversimplification you'll see all
these bonds between these carbons
and to make those bonds requires energy
and if you were to break those bonds it
could release energy and you might say
well where did all these carbons come
from that are in this tree
well the carbon is coming from the air
our air has carbon dioxide in it it has
carbon dioxide so those are the carbons
maybe let me draw some oxygens so two
oxygens for every carbon
and the whole process of photosynthesis
is all about fixing that carbon let me
write that word down we are fixing
fixing
that carbon
in from a gaseous form when it's part of
carbon dioxide into the structure of the
plant into into the biological molecules
of the plant so it's storing that energy
now it's not a perfectly efficient
process not all of the energy from the
sun is going to be able to be stored
some of it is being reflected even the
plant itself as it as it goes as it
lives as it reproduces as its cells
divide
some of that energy is used and
eventually that energy is released as
heat and you're going to see this trend
a lot in thermodynamic systems that
you are taking you're going from one
energy you're using energy to do some
work but in the process you are going to
be producing heat
but this is just the beginning of our of
our energy flow now we can think about
how that energy now flows to the other
actors in the ecosystem so the next
phase and this is a very simplified
diagram or ecosystem that we're thinking
about most ecosystems are far far far
more complex let's think about the
characters that would eat the plants the
characters that would eat the primary
producers and we call the folks that eat
the primary producers we call them
primary consumers
so this bunny or this squirrel right
over here they are primary
primary consumers they consume the
primary producers and why do they
consume them why do why does a bunny eat
the grass well because it gets energy
from those bonds between in the
biological molecules from those carbon
bonds and and other bonds
and it's able to use that energy to grow
itself
to reproduce to live
to run around and it also stores some of
that energy in its own biomass and once
again this process is not very efficient
going from one layer of trophy
to another layer of trophy you only have
about 10 percent
10 of the energy gets transferred or
gets stored in the next get stored in
the next layer why only 10
well because
not all of the plants get eaten
the whole process of eating plants
digesting plants some of the energy gets
some of the energy it gets pooped out
gets pooped out
because the the primary consumer here or
the consumer isn't able to get all of it
out of the actual biological molecules
and so overall it's an inefficient
process
now we're not done yet we still have
energy stored in the biological
molecules of this primary consumer that
someone might be interested in and we
know that in many ecosystems there are
things that like to eat rabbits or even
squirrels and in this drawing it will be
this fox and this fox because it eats
primary consumers we would call it a
secondary consumer
the secondary
consumer and you could keep going on
with this if there was some
character out here let's say there's
some guy
who likes to eat foxes that's a knife in
his hand that he uses to go after the
foxes with well
so the fox could go to him and once
again why is he eating foxes well he
wants that energy in that fox and
actually some of them is actually not
just about molecules we'll talk about
matter in a second he wants the energy
and the matter from the fox to grow and
live himself and so this character would
be called a tertiary consumer
tertiary
consumer
and if there's no one who wants to eat
him well then he would be considered a
an apex consumer or an apex predator and
these characters that eat other animals
we've talked about it before they're
called carnivore carnivores but let me
just say he's the apex and apex really
thinking about the top of the food chain
that's why they're called that would be
called an apex consumer or an apex
predator
but we're not done yet because at some
point all of these characters whether
we're talking about the trees the
bunnies the fox this this character who
likes to eat foxes
they're going to die and that energy
just doesn't disappear and in general
you're going to see energy is conserved
and it flows from one place to another
that energy is then going to be used by
it is going to be used by these
characters right over here which we call
decomposers they can take all that
leftover energy in that that dead
carcass or even in the poop and they can
make use of it once again for them to
live for them to reproduce
and then and and then they by breaking
that down they they can release a lot of
those nutrients and the matter that's
used and once again the matter is
recycled once again to be used to be
used by the plants so it creates this
really nice cycle and the important
thing to realize is it comes in as light
that energy gets transferred as we go to
through the layer different layers of
trophy uh and
and it's not a completely efficient
process and a lot of that energy
especially as we as these organisms live
and reproduce and run around gets
released as heat
now we focus a lot on the energy let's
think a little bit about the matter and
i've already touched on it but the
matter is recycled there isn't uh at
least the way we've set this up there
isn't new matter that is entering or
leaving these ecosystems or being
magically created or magically destroyed
as i mentioned when you look at a leaf
on a on a plant growing or tree growing
or a leave of grass growing that matter
isn't just coming out of nowhere it's
coming out of the it's it's just a
different form or maybe the best way to
put it that matter was always there in
the form of carbon dioxide the plant is
just using that energy from the sun to
fix that carbon from a gas form into
into a solid form and it's able to use
that energy to form bonds by bonds
between the carbons in these biological
molecules that actually store energy and
the plant can use that energy to grow
and as we've talked about things that
eat the plants or things that eat the
things that eat the plants can use that
energy
and as we talked before the carbon
dioxide comes in these plants and maybe
this this arrow might be a little bit
misleading so
let me
erase that let me erase that for now but
we release oxygen
o2
that oxygen
and we've seen that as part of the
photosynthesis process that oxygen is
used by the animals to
metabolize these biological molecules we
study that in biology in respiration and
the matter itself as we say we have this
carbon right over here when it gets
eaten well then that becomes part of the
biomolecules inside
inside of this inside of this bunny and
when the bunny uses those any of these
biological molecules as a source of
energy so it's able to break those bonds
through respiration well then that
carbon that carbon gets released in the
form of carbon
in the form of carbon dioxide so maybe
this is a better way and actually it was
already drawn right over here
and so the important thing to realize is
that energy is flowing light from the
sun comes in it's slow you know all this
action goes on and then it gets released
at heat as heat on almost every step but
the matter itself it's always been there
all of the atoms in our body on earth
it's just constantly being recycled it's
actually was generated inside of stars
many many billions of years ago and we
just keep reusing it over and over and
over again it gets recycled from one
form to another even after all of these
these biological after these actors die
the decomposers break them down into
simple inorganic molecules as we talked
about
before that can then be used as the
plants in conjunction with the carbon
from the air and the light from the sun
and
water that it gets through its roots to
start that process all over
all over again